[Music]
some say the world will end in fire some
say in ice from what i've tasted of
desire i hold with those who favor fire
but if it had to perish twice i think i
know enough of hate to know that for
destruction ice is also great and would
suffice we don't know exactly how the
country is going to collapse when it
will collapse if it will collapse at all
and there's a big debate on the right
right now about
whether we're in late imperial rome late
republican rome maybe we're not in rome
at all one of the clearest most profound
essays i have read on this topic came
from my friend mike anton lecturer in
politics and research fellow at the
hillsdale college's kirby center in dc
mike is the author of the stakes mike
served on the national security council
staff under president donald trump he's
done lots of interesting things
and mike
is going to clarify for us i hope on
exactly what is going to happen next in
american politics sir thank you for
being here thank you unfortunately the
the clarity that i can offer is the
clarity of saying we don't know
so i i am a i am a dabbler more than a
dabbler in these historical comparisons
we all have um in fact some of the
some of the criticisms or commentaries
on the article have been oh there he
goes again talking you know it's that
done to death rome comparison right but
i felt it had to be summarized precisely
because it is so done to death and so
dominant we had to acknowledge that look
this is the comparison everybody wants
to make but my point isn't to say that
we're going to follow that track it was
to start by saying there's a reason
people make a comparison because there
are a number of similarities that's not
the focus of this article focus of this
article are the differences and not just
the differences between america and rome
the differences between what the
situation in the united states is today
and from what i can tell
the differences between that and
anything that's come before you there
are things in which you grope to find a
historical parallel and you can't find
one now i will preface this this is this
call this false modesty or what you will
um i'm not a historian i i did one of my
three college majors was history i think
i'm above average in historical learning
and understanding but by no means an
expert so i've always
there are a lot of caveats in the
articles that say i don't think this has
ever happened before i will state a
certain phenomena and then say i can't
think of an example of this if there are
people out there who want to say no no
anton you know here's the point you made
on page 19 or whatever but in fact
there's a direct
you know the cappadocian empire of 378
bc went through exactly this i'm all i'm
all ears i want to hear it but what i
was trying to do was show
a series of things that i think are
unprecedented and that because they're
unprecedented they make
predictions difficult or impossible
and they
put us in a sense uncharted territory so
even even the rome comparison as apt and
useful as it is for many reasons
ultimately can't
can't serve us as a guide
so for those who have not yet read the
entire essay and i would strongly
encourage people to do so because we are
awash in a sea of political commentary
and most of it's crap but this one's
actually quite illuminating
what exactly is unprecedented about our
situation compared to every other
historical example well i believe i i
begin with immigration migration
population change obviously that's
happened over the years i mean you know
anything about history you know that
people move around a lot and and not
just individuals but families and tribes
and even almost whole nations can
migrate so this is how that has happened
before
what i point to in this case is
the rapidity
okay point one uh the the sheer numbers
point two and they use one of the great
buzzwords of our time the diversity
point three now this is before you
before you take a position on the
goodness or badness consequential
consequentiality or irrelevance of this
let's just face the facts i by my count
and it's it's a rough and dirty count
because i'm not a demographer but i
looked at all the best sources i could
find reputable sources like pew research
center
you count up how many people have come
legally
since 1965 immigration act changed the
u.s policy you you do your best to
estimate how many have come illegally
and you do your best to estimate um you
know the their descendants of children
and grandchildren um and i would say
that it's about 100 million over
50 to 55 years it could be 90 it could
be 110 but let's just it's about 100
million um
you know in that brief a period has
never happened before you go back to
some of the great mass migrations in
history that's just never happened
before the other thing is the the
diversity so
lots of people are coming to the united
states um
but they're coming from literally
everywhere this has never happened
before because the technology wasn't
around so if you in the ancient world or
in the early medieval world if you
wanted to cross the danube and go into
italy or go try to see if what was left
of the western roman empire you could do
that but you weren't coming from the
central asian steps you weren't coming
from sub-saharan africa or the cone of
south america because there was no way
for you to get there now you can come
from anywhere because transportation is
is is easy by historical standards and
so not only do we have the greatest
number of people entering one country
over the shortest period of time we also
have the widest variety of sources and
that includes differences in religion
language culture
uh outlook you name it and
it's just never it's never happened
before now we're told
diversity is our strength i quote which
by the way
i have to the best of my knowledge found
no earlier source for than a dan quail
if you can imagine that speech from
1992.
um
well you know historically and
philosophically diversity beyond a
certain point has not been thought of as
a strength uh i quote aristotle's
politics where he says look
ethnic conflict basically happens
whenever two peoples from a different
source get together and he's talking
about differences between greeks of so
fine a shade from our distance we
wouldn't even recognize the difference
right if you were to say to him well mr
aristotle we can one-up you here we've
got you know we've got three
uh abrahamic faiths and then we've got
eastern face and then we've got people
of no faith or this that and then we get
into the linguistic stuff which makes
the tower of babel look like um you know
an average high school that offers
spanish and french and that's about it
uh he would be astonished and say yeah i
don't know how this is going to work out
there's a funny moment in dante when
dante is up going up to heaven and he
meets with his one illustrious ancestor
from whom he gets his uh family name and
this is the one guy kachuguida and
kachuguida who is in heaven he's saved
he's a saint he he laments
how everything was better in florence
before all the immigrants came in
it's a little bit of a politically
incorrect moment but that would be the
historical understanding of things
yeah i mean look people like to well i
like to quote mikey billy but on this
specific point you know mikey valley
praises immigration as one of the
sources of strength that made rome great
basically he's pretty blunt about this
though it was because of the manpower
just needed a lot of people to put
together these big armies and go around
and conquer the world but if you read
him a little more carefully he also says
this really changed ultimately the
republican character of ancient rome so
there's a parallel that may be apt um
for us i just think you know like i said
i start off with
the number
the speed and the diversity and i don't
think that that's
ever happened before
um
i go into the character of our ruling
class which i'm not a fan of i think
i've made that plain enough in various
writings and podcasts and other talks um
but you know a rapacious elite that
doesn't serve the interests of the
people it
governs that's not new i mean that's
happened before it's the particular
character of our elite that i'm not sure
has ever happened before i was just
reading last night again because i think
i'm going to do a little a class on this
you know xenophon cyrapadia and some of
the commentaries or and then i went
through a passage in xenophon's hyro
where jairo has to say you know
no tyrant wants a healthy people you got
to kind of keep him down you got to keep
them half broken because the healthy
people are the ones that are going to
come and overthrow you all right yeah
that's that's fairly common but i mean
has any tyrant ever pushed you know
transgenderism
and some so many of the
crazy things that are being pushed on us
today
and we're demanded to accept them before
uh this is new i mean popular manias
they've certainly happened before but
the types and the speed with which these
things are happening um they seem they
seem new to me and the determination the
the current ruling class is going well
beyond what it needs to do to keep the
people um
uh unwilling or unlikely to rise up and
revolt against them and seems to want to
punish them in a punitive way that
i i don't have a whole lot of uh horse
historical antecedents for that i can
draw on
there does seem to be a kind of
masochism as well and and this is hard
to wrap one's mind around which is that
it's not merely the elite pushing all
these sorts of pathologies on the plebs
and on all
they're pushing them on themselves in a
way too you know when the
largely white liberal ruling class
pushes anti-white racism through
critical race theory or what whatever
other phenomenon
presumably at some point this is going
to come back to haunt them when they
push the radical gender theories
many of their own children have fallen
prey to that so what what what are they
thinking
i
i don't know uh i've been i
puzzle over this a lot i think i say in
the article that you know they
and excuse me is exactly what you say
this is kind of in in a sense it's an
intro white fight
a largely white ruling class hates
a largely or an even more mostly white
middle or working class
and so in order to attack them condemns
the whole white race and then tries to
exempt itself but they don't have a
coherent or convincing reason why this
doesn't apply to them you're just
supposed to sort of know that if you're
if you hold the right opinions if you
went to the right school if you work in
the right job if you live in the right
blue metro area you're okay you're not a
bad person but if they were to spell it
out you know there's this group over
here that's bad and we're okay they know
that that somehow that doesn't work
rhetorically and they can't make it
consistent they can't uh make it sound
consistent and they also know that many
of the people to whom their hateful
rhetoric appeals don't want to hear a
distinction they want the blanket
condemnation so they give them that red
meat blanket condemnation that's
probably the wrong phrase to use some of
these people are probably eating soy but
whatever
they give them that blanket confirmation
and then they just try to pretend that
it doesn't count to us and i say exactly
what you just said which is they're
they're banking on a hope that this will
never turn around and bite them but this
will not blow back on them in any way
and for the most part so far it hasn't
although you could say it kind of is
right i mean these ruling class citadels
are the ones suffering the most you
wouldn't want to be in chicago right now
right that maybe that's not the heart of
the ruling class but manhattan certainly
is down san francisco certainly is and
these places are suffering badly from
crime from homelessness from the
mentally ill and the drug addicted on
the streets from anti-social behavior of
all types and precisely because they
don't have a coherent
way to convey this well we're exempt
from this judgment but you're not
they've now so they they used to be
better hypocrites that is to say it used
to be that the ruling class would say
you know yes we need we need bail reform
we need criminal justice reform we need
all of this stuff but not in manhattan
manhattan needs 40 you know new york
city needs 40 000 cops a strong jail
system um serious district attorneys and
we've got to get everything under
control
even though that was hypocritical and
the logic didn't lead you there they
would say it anyway now
they're so bought into their own
arguments that they watch as their own
citadels get torched and they go yeah i
can't i have nothing to say against i
can't even be a hypocrite and oppose
that
you know it's a marvel to watch they're
not
yet waking up to what degree you alluded
to this earlier to what degree is this a
technological problem meaning you
couldn't have had the largest migration
of people in ever in human history
before the technology permitted it and
and on the other side of that one of the
things that we hear or one of the great
praises we hear of all this modern
upheaval is well at least you've got
your iphones you know we live in this
modern we have the metaverse we have
video games we have robots injecting you
with things we have all the
wonder wonderments of of technology so
how do we grapple with that well i don't
i mean grapple with the the the real
expert on this who you should talk to is
is james poulos who i will say textified
before congress uh
i guess late last week um and got kudos
from the
members of congress who understood him
which sadly given the
quality of members of congress probably
wasn't as many as we would like
nonetheless it
technical or so this technology does a
couple things one is i i definitely i
don't think or at least i suspect that
it would not be possible for
wokeness and this kind of mental
pathology to be as virulent and as
widespread as it is absent social media
which is a relatively new phenomena in
human in even in our own lives i mean
there's no social media when i'm a kid
yeah um in fact it's often pointed out
you know people around my age will be
the last generation to grow up entirely
untouched by this it comes around when
you're only when you're an adult and
therefore it didn't really get its hooks
into you well everybody born after a
certain point never knew a world without
it
and it completely shaped the way that
they look at things another aspect
though of the phone and of the screens
which i do point out in the piece is
it's it's an attempt by the regime
for lack of a better term to just drug
us it's like we you know inflation is
really high crime is up you're not going
to get a the kind of job you want your
degree is worthless well we're going to
make it up to you by
with streaming and and screens and
scrolling um and the more you're
preoccupied with that this gets back to
the point this is sort of precedented
right this gets back to jairo's point i
want to put the citizenry to sleep so
that they don't come after me well in
the ancient world you couldn't do it
with screens in the modern world you can
so there are aspects to the screens that
i think have historical head precedent
and there are aspects that don't well it
does it does make you wonder too
if the great achievement of the age is
all the streams and the tweets and the
likes and and sending you all sorts of
weird creepy sexualized images
how productive is that is that is you
know when i think of the the
technological innovation of the vacuum
cleaner that seems to be much more
productive than twitter that's
definitely true i i
i intuit i can't say i know but i intuit
that we're living through and actually a
pretty non-productive age and one of the
reasons why everything feels so fake and
the economy has to be
you know jerry-rigged in certain ways
and the numbers fudged and and and
pumped up with fiat money and all of
this is because there really isn't any
underlying productivity going on or very
little um all this prosperity kind of
feels
ephemeral and illusory and
it's possible that the inflation that
we're now enduring and which is
apparently slated to get a lot worse
is a side of that
those kinds of things though have
precedence let me get back to something
you said earlier which is this this this
the self-loathing
is unprecedented i i struggled to find i
found you know plenty of historical
examples of nations that fell or just
sort of went through a long decline
this mass hatred and it's not just in
the united states you're seeing it in
europe in certain countries or parts of
certain countries you're seeing it
around the world
i don't know that that's ever happened
before
i mentioned the
fertility rates at one point
when has have not just one country but
you know a dozen or two dozen countries
ever have fertility rates so far below
replacement that demographers are
talking about potential extinction
i'm not sure that's going to happen
anything can happen and things may turn
around but
it's it it's bizarre and
kind of scary to watch
you just you see
rises and falls
depending on
material considerations external
considerations political considerations
but
um
you know i don't think we've ever seen
an extended period of such low rates in
so many countries all at the same time
like we're seeing today but what you're
describing mike is a situation where the
native populations of a number of
countries and notably our own is
declining rapidly and there's
simultaneously a massive wave of
migration from all over the world
uh but i was just recently reading the
splc and reading msnbc and cnn and i am
told that is a wild
racist evil conspiracy theory called the
great replacement how dare you unless
they say it unless it's okay um that's
true because they do admit it
that they say we're replacing you
because you're bad that's great if i say
so you're replacing me because i'm bad
they say how dare you
right because one of the things that i
find you know propaganda has also been
around forever
but
the techniques that they're using now i
don't know that have precedent
essentially they
they require you to lie on their behalf
right so michael we're going to replace
you wait you're going to replace b
michael i didn't say that how dare you
now tell me after immediately after i
say your response should be you never
said it all right repeat after me
michael i'm going to replace you your
response is you're not going to replace
me that's what they expect us to do and
they punish us if we don't play along
there was an article i forget it was the
new york times or washington post i
guess there have been actually many
articles to this effect but but there
was one i remember in particular where
the headline was
yes we are replacing yours no it was it
was we can replace them
yeah that's right it's still there and
and i think that michelle goldberg was
the was the uh author and
she will be one of the first to condemn
you if you you know quoting their own
words back to them is a is a sin now
this is a a
phenomenon that i've looked at in other
venues and tried to explain they have a
messaging problem i'm actually writing
about this right now and i haven't
finished the piece they have a messaging
problem which is that part of their
message is to
um
rile up their shock troops again this is
part of what the with but what the the
really uh viral and anti-white rhetoric
is about just rile up the shock troops
and that could include non-whites who
are anti-white but also some whites who
really have taken it they've drunk the
kool-aid and they believe whiteness is
bad and if they're they're guilty of
original sin by being born of this
particular race they need to use that
rhetoric to rile up their base
but it's hard to do that in private so
that others don't hear it and think wow
that sounds like anti-white hatred that
sounds kind of racist so they can't not
say it they just have to they have to
condemn you for noticing and for saying
it back
so that's part of the part of the
rhetorical ploy we get to say it you
don't get to say it in fact we require
you to deny that we said it
it's this seems unstable and i suppose
it is unstable and you see that breakout
in
the inability to control some of the
riots and things that that were in no
small part racial last year and actually
speaking of those riots
you you've mentioned george floyd the
patron saint of contemporary leftism as
a real as an emblem of this movement and
also as unprecedented well look
i said
whichever position one takes about the
specific circumstances of his death in
the outcome of the trial right and the
official position the only one
you know this is a basically catechism
for the regime at this point is he was
murdered he was an innocent lamb who was
murdered that's it you are not allowed
to have any other opinion okay
even if you accept that insistence by
the regime as i think i put it in the
article
one would have to say that george floyd
did not live his life in a way to make
such a death improbable that is to say
you can go back and it's in the public
record as much as they try to suppress
it and it can't all be suppressed so
essentially it's taboo to talk about his
life you can't mention all the
convictions you can't mention all the
arrests you can't mention many of the
crimes and many of them and many of the
very bad things that he did because only
a bad person would mention that but
they're they're out there and i say if
you if you look at all of this
even if you think he was completely
innocent at the uh in the circumstance
at which he did die
the
ridiculous i find response to his death
i mean and tragic response to his death
i mean cities burned lives lost a crime
wave that we're still in the midst of a
year and a half later that shows as yet
no signs of slowing down but also if you
remember he got the equivalent of like
three state funerals and drawn in
horse-drawn carriages with celebrities
joe biden in attendance thousands of
people i mean
you know this is like i can sort of get
it you know bob dole just died he lied
he landed state in the capitol and then
went to the national cathedral all right
somebody like that who served his
country honorably in war was a a senior
statement a presidential candidate you
sort of get those levels of honors for a
person like bob dole
for george floyd and whom to whom
statues have been erected around the
country murals painted around the
country the the the intersection where
he died has been sort of made into a
holy space that you know
i just have to say this is not a person
who lived his life to be worthy of that
level of admiration
and i don't recall i can't think of
another instance of a whole country a
whole civilization
elevating someone like that even if they
really were a martyr in the specific
circumstance but elevating someone like
that overall
to
almost a kind of
godhood in a way
even the catholic university of america
just recently it was revealed
had an icon up of what would have been
the madonna and the pieta of mary and
jesus after the crucifixion except it
was
a black woman and a black man and the
black man according to the artist is a a
george floyd and this was the catholic
university of america so we're we're
seeing in some cases explicit religious
iconography
yeah i mean look it's an over quoted
phrase but i'll quote it again anyway
you know the famous chesterton when
people stop believing in in god they
don't believe in nothing they believe in
anything i mean the
lack of religiosity the lack of
something genuine to look up to it
believes in the human i completely
believe this it leaves in the human soul
a vacuum that must be filled
and it can be filled with preposterous
and even destructive enthusiasms which
is unfortunately what we're going
through now now that's not new that's
not unprecedented the specific nature of
what we're going through now though i
believe
is unprecedented well speaking of
religion and catholicism i before i let
you go i have to touch on this final
point that you made in the essay which
is look i try to avoid the near occasion
of sin okay i try i don't want to look
lustfully on any image but for all of my
life especially growing up in new york i
look up at billboards and images and
it's all these hot chickies wearing not
a lot of clothing and because we are
told sex sells yeah and
you know the only thing worse than that
i guess than all those hot chickies in
lingerie would be not hot chickies
wearing lingerie which is what appears
to be happening all around us no they're
forcing they want to say that
um look this gets to be actually a
fairly profound topic so i will try not
to go on too long but you know in the
ancient ancient philosophy
there's a bedrock assumption that there
that beauty is a real metaphysical
category that's immutable it's not in
the eye of the beholder in other words
which is a phrase everybody knows if you
look it up it's actually from a book
that's utterly forgotten nobody
remembers the title or the author that
includes me i i have to look it up again
it's only known for this one phrase
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
which basically means all aesthetic
standards are relative right right if
we're just sticking with aesthetics now
if we're going to take the greek beauty
could be more than just how something
looks you know there could be the beauty
of a thought the beauty of a concept and
a lot but let's just stick with
aesthetics right it's all uh completely
relative is what that notion means
now that's actually not true it's not
the way people perceive the world or
live their life most people just on a
gut level can tell beauty from
mediocrity or from just ordinariness all
the way down to ugliness and what the
regime is doing is is in the name of
pure relativism eye of the beholder it's
basically it wants to say those who have
or or traits that have up to now been
considered not beautiful we're going to
promote and we're going to hit you in
the back of the head and we're going to
say you will consider these beautiful or
else right we're going to and i dare you
to say that that obese
woman with the piercings and and all of
the other stuff that you know
conventionally would not be considered
beautiful staring down
uh at you from eight stories up as you
walk by the street i dare you it's
to say she's not beautiful because we'll
punish you for that because that just
shows that you're whatever add the the
suffix ist
you're this system you know you're
racist you're you're sexist you're
i don't know fattest or thinnest and
what is it what does it mean i mean
i guess to be against something you are
that is so if you're
phobical
am i fat phobic i don't know i mean i
like chesterton i mean he was kind of
but i don't want to see it on uh
billboards in lingerie i mean look the
fact of the matter is i mean pick a name
you know uh from either whether from the
past you know grace kelly is prettier
was prettier than
a modern laundry it's just the and and
99.9 of human beings that's their gut
instinct and you can you can bludgeon
them into professing the opposite but
it's tyrannical to do so and it's not
ultimately effective they don't they
won't believe it in their hearts if you
say which one do you think is uh you
know which one do you rate the 10 and
which one do you write the one
they're going to make almost everyone's
going to make the same choice every time
because that's ingrained in our nature
and older thinkers both in the religious
tradition and in the philosophic
tradition had this right and that's not
something that i think can be changed
but this this is true the phenomenon and
our reaction to it is true beyond the
lingerie models this this is true of
architecture there's this strange fact
that in the back half of the 20th
century
beautiful buildings stopped being made
and buildings that formerly were
beautiful were made uglier why why i i
totally agree that they're doing this
and that they are forcing us to say that
some hideous brutalist building is
gorgeous and you know it's just like the
lingerie model but
why are they doing why um good question
i mean my my go-to books on this um
which i
heartily recommend to people because
they're immensely entertaining and as
well as learned now a true critic would
say these these are not serious and this
shows that anton is a philistine i don't
care that's i'm rejecting their theories
are the painted word
and from bauhaus to our house both by
tom wolf
and there was it was both a sense of
well all this other stuff has been done
to death so we got to come up with
something new um but then there was very
specific theories that the modernists
had you know um that that come out of
the philosophic tradition or not
tradition i'm sorry but the rejection of
the philosophic tradition that you know
well it's time to shock the bourgeoisie
it's time to trans-evaluate our val all
values it's time to undermine the
bourgeois and these kinds of things and
this gets translated into art and
architecture so that
it becomes almost obligatory look i have
to drive through downtown washington
pretty frequently
and
cheek by jowl you will see beautiful
neoclassical buildings
with monstrosities
and any as you say anything built after
a certain period of time well almost
is a monstrosity and also wolf wolf does
point out the extent to which
um
it's just a fad that the intellectuals
sort of put one over on the patrons who
are paying for it and the patrons deep
in their heart don't like it but they
feel like they've gotta go along go with
the flow otherwise they'll be thought of
as rubes i think i i used to know this
from memory and i'll probably get it
somewhat wrong but the very first
sentence from bauhaus to our house goes
something like oh beautiful for spacious
skies and amber waves of grain
has ever in the history of the world so
many wealthy people paid for so much
architecture they absolutely detest it
and he goes into like the guys like i'm
i'm a corporate ceo or i'm the chairman
of the board and i'm building my new
building and i have visions of what it
should be and then the slick architects
with the horn rims round glasses come in
and they go no it's going to be a steel
glass box take it or leave it and i do
it even though i hate it
because i can't bear the shame these
guys have social status over me they're
superior to me in the not in terms of
money not in terms of power or what they
could do in society but somehow their
status as intellectuals and cultural
arbiters is so high that i have to just
eat it and do what they want i saw this
recently i was on a subway in manhattan
and
actually going back to the model
description there was an ugly model
selling some type of clothing and the
messaging the words on the on this page
said
that this was a revolution and if you
bought this particular set of clothes
you were participating in a revolution
and you see this aesthetic revolution
where beauty will be repressed and
ugliness will be will be promoted and
demanded by the regime so in the
few moments that we have left
on the topic of revolution
if you were a gambling man mike how does
this all end here in our beloved u.s of
a
uh i'm not a gambling man and i end the
article exactly on this point saying i
don't know i'm the
the closest thing to a conclusion that
i'm willing to give is that going along
on woke america seems like a sucker bet
i don't think this can go on for much
longer um and i've had this debate with
others you know in particular this is a
point that
curtis yarvin and i come back to a lot
he thinks the present situation can just
basically last indefinitely i think
that's obviously wrong in part because
nothing lasts indefinitely but because
it's so obviously incompetent
anti-natural unsustainable i mean
you know okay
america's been through crime waves
before um i've lived through the 70s as
a fairly young kid to be
to be fair um
and i've certainly read about the john
lindsay era and the insanities in the
bay area of the of the 70s 60s and 70s i
just wrote a piece about this it'll be
out in first things one soon
um i've never seen anything like this
though where
rioters sack downtowns
and all of the corporate leaders in the
city and the mayor and everybody maybe
the police chief is the only dissenter
say you go for it you know this is you
know what's the mayor of baltimore
people need space to destroy we should
let them do that that's never happened
before i mean how can how can that last
how can a situation like this last for
10 or 20 or 50 years
you never know because our situation is
unprecedented
something
unprecedented longevity for dysfunction
and psychopathy could be a feature of it
but if there is nature as i and many
like me and many who have read my the
same books and the authors of those
books for that matter if there is nature
as we understand it then this can't last
don't ask me when it ends but i it can't
last that's a sort of consolation
although it's a consolation with that
conservative optimist caveat that things
could of course get much much worse but
it is a consolation that it won't remain
like this forever everyone has to go
read the essay it's terrific
unprecedented by michael anton in the
new criterion i look forward to the the
new essay coming out in first things and
uh mike thank you as always for being
here thank you love love love to see you
as ever
[Music]
[Music]
you